okay
well hey everyone um welcome to the
july 2021 pi data triangle meetup
um today we'll have two different
speakers talking about the same subject
which i'll get into
after some announcements
um yeah as always uh velassis digital
sponsors this conference um molasses
digital
is an advertising and marketing company
that predicts
consumer behavior and compels or builds
compelling media moments for brands
usually we have this at the velasus
offices but
during the pandemic we are on zoom
and we and we are our name has changed
to vericast
um so we're in the process of working
through that marketing transition
vericast um
yeah uh another one of pi data's
sponsors is num focus
and num focus is a non-profit that
promotes open practices
in research data and computing
as always here's our code of conduct i'm
sure most of you have read this
by now but um just a quick refresher pi
data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free conference experience
for everyone so
please be kind and professional
so don't be mean be average or be above
average
almost mess that up good to say that
because we have the troublemakers here
yeah um another announcement we've gone
by monthly and have been for a while now
so our next meetup will be
um september 1st 2021 at 6 p.m
on zoom
a question we've been asking recently is
how can we serve
content that you want or need so if any
of you have like data science topics
that interest you
if you want to give a talk or you know
someone who'd like to give a talk
if there are any activities that you
want to organize please reach out to
mark dhruv
jean or i either on pi data
or or on meetup or on email
or you can ping me here
um yeah so before we get into the talk
does anyone have any event announcements
or job opportunities they'd like to
share
arte yes if anyone's interested in the
alteryx
designer user group uh we are meeting in
august august 18. uh we don't have the
announcement up yet but
i'll just post a link to the linkedin
group
sounds good thank you yeah
and bearcats bearcast is um has a
a few positions open for marketing
scientists and data scientists
and engineers um i think there's there's
probably
two or three openings in each one of
those areas
no need to have ad tech experience
but i think all three of those positions
are looking for
five years or more experience
i just let one other note you know we
are really shooting
to do this uh as a physical meet up in
november it won't be september
but we're really hoping that we can get
the november back into
sort of a dinner and uh presentation
night
at our offices in morrisville
i really miss the free food
and arthi actually there is an opening
that i would like to
say i'm working at central square which
is a public administration and public
safety company
we have a few software developer
positions open
product manager positions open uh
qa engineer positions open and we have
a number of product owner positions open
as well as the
product support positions
cool um yeah
as always please post any links in the
chat if you have them
um yeah anyone else
another thing to keep in mind so we'll
have our lightning talks um
at the very end after our two speakers
present
so if you have an idea for a lightning
talk please ping me in the chat
and i can kind of schedule that in for
the end
awesome okay so i'll kind of introduce
both of our speakers at once because
there will be presenting on the same
topic which is
how to distill amazon reviews into a
representative subset
so our first speaker is leo
and he recently completed his masters of
science degree
in computer science and information
systems at uncw
focusing mainly on database management
leo
is currently a full stack software
developer at central squares technology
so he'll be talking about he'll be kind
of giving like a project overview
um and about selecting optimal subsets
of amazon reviews
um our next speaker is brian woodall
ryan has a masters of science degree in
computer science and information systems
as his capstone project he designed and
implemented a fully automated data
pipeline for collecting and preparing
amazon reviews
and since receiving his degree this year
he works as a mentor for aspiring high
school students through polygyns
and is currently exploring job
opportunities in data engineering and
related fields
so he'll be speaking about the data
engineering side
so large scale data pipeline for
scraping the amazon reviews
and before we get into it mark shared um
an interesting quote that's kind of
related to what
what we'll be talking about today that
might spur your interest so
it reads if similarity search is at the
heart of
the success of a 1.6 trillion dollar
company
um google there's a good chance it's
worth learning more about
so with that i'll stop sharing and then
leo if you want to kick us off
sounds good honesty okay how do i stop
sharing
there we go all right
and be sure i should go to slideshow
from the beginning okay so my thesis
topic was on automated text reduction
and comparison of reduced reading list
creation models
this was inspired by klein's 1998 paper
which was a working paper that he did
not
complete and experiment with but he had
some ideas
that i thought were worthwhile to look
at
in my presentation i will state the
problem talk about the metrics
optimization models data the numerical
representation of text data
results and then discussion and then
limitations in future research
but before that let's talk about
what's the problem you're trying to
solve and look at
now with the growing exponential growth
in the
technology there are more and more
information
being entered into internet and other
data sources now with this
exponential growth it is it is becoming
really hard to read
uh documents and get the information
when you have high redundancy within
documents
and across documents so we said
can we just select some of them and
by reading them get most of the overall
corpus
so if we had 100 reviews or 100
documents
is there a way to pick three that would
represent the overall
the best and the second
important part of our project was
making it in a way that it is easily
repeatable so this methods
we use should be able to apply to
any data set in similar format without
requiring any changes
so things like stop words or um
term elimination or dimension reduction
we try to make it
in a really standard way so that it is
reputable now actually before going into
too much detail
uh what let me tell you what dr klein
did
in the previous presentation uh at that
stage i had
the data collected from amazon using the
web scraper tool
and based on that data we looked at some
statistics on the data such as the
review counts and the dictionary
which means the overall vocabulary of
corpus and we try to visualize it
using the word clouds and
some histograms at that stage
it was only about the overall corpus we
did not go into details of specific
reviews
but after that we actually applied
uh the reviews
for specific models described in uh
klein's
1998 paper so for now i think this is
sufficient information about the project
in my second part i will actually talk
about the implementation of this
process
so uh ryan will you be talking about the
data engineering portion
yes i can get into that now let me uh
share my screen
wait i'm in trouble here shared
this
there it is
okay
so what i did was uh
i created a data pipeline
that's fully automated for uh scraping
amazon reviews and
um collect collecting them and preparing
them for
data scientists or whatever means
so first a little bit
this is what i wanted to talk about uh
just a little bit about me
and then i'll go over to system overview
and i'll talk a little bit about the web
scraper i used and
and some of the azure components uh as
well as the data transformations that i
had to do
and then a lot of the issues that i ran
into with time and money
so i grew up in smithfield north
carolina
uh home of the
bright leaf hot dogs and ham and yam
festival not too far from
a lot of y'all received my bachelor's
degree
way back uh i think it should have been
around 99
um and but that was in music uh
and you can kind of see some of my
pictures there of me on gigs
in 2005 i started working at measurement
incorporated
which is based out of durham but i
worked at the wilmington site
basically they grade standardized tests
and as a scoring director i oversaw the
training and scoring of those
but in 2007 i returned to uncw
to get the map get a master's degree in
computer science and information systems
and that's
where i met dr klein and uh and became
interested in
data management science and engineering
and this brings me to my capstone
project which is related
as said to the work of leo and
it's part of a greater project dr klein
is working on
um so now i'm getting to the details of
this project
so first of all the system requirements
basically what i was looking for from a
big picture standpoint
is i wanted to be able to input a csv
file that was basically just a list of
product urls
and each product url was the starting
page for uh
the reviews for that for that amazon
product
and then it would create scraping jobs
for each product url
retrieve the scrape data and clean the
data and add it to a relational model
and finally output a json file of the
entire collection of amazon reviews
some additional requirements were that
it needed to be fully automated
exist entirely in the cloud and utilize
a third-party
cloud-based web scraper that dr klein
and leo were already using
and i'll dig in get deeper into the
components of the system
but uh bear with me because there's a
lot of moving parts and it's difficult
to really figure out the best order to
present everything without jumping
around just a little bit
so this kind of shows the system
overview
so you can see it it does exist
entirely in the cloud and most of the
work happens within azure cloud services
but as again the web scraper part of it
that is a third-party service which i
didn't have to create but i did have to
configure components
to integrate between it and in azure
basically
by means of http uh posts
and things like that and the azure
services
i was basically using a sql database a
data lake
function app and data factory
before i get into azure services i want
to talk a little bit about the uh
the web scraper
so webscraper.io is the free version and
it comes in the the form of a browser
extension
uh it offers usual user-friendly tools
that allow you to basically
point and click and to generate a site
map
which is um basically the
instructions for the scraper in the form
of a json file
there's a lot of tutorials and
documentation so it's pretty easy to
create these site maps with only
minimal knowledge of html unfortunately
i couldn't use the free version because
i needed everything to be automated
but i will point out that the sitemap
was originally created
using the browser extension and then it
was passed along to me
the cloud version of this scraper it
offers api access
which would allow the ultimate
automation that i needed
but it's not cheap and i'll get to the
cost a few sides down
um what i needed the api to do was
uh basically for creating the site maps
and and the scraping jobs
and then to be able to retrieve the data
and
delete the jobs um
so for to scrape reviews for a product
you actually need
need that sitemap first and you have to
create that
for each product so for each product url
but the site map is it's pretty much
exactly the same for each product with
the exception of
of two fields and uh
i've highlighted those there this is not
the entire site map this is just the
beginning it's
several pages long but you can see that
uh i've highlighted the two fields that
you that are different for each product
and it's basically just the name and
then the uh
start page the url for the starting page
and this is where the url comes from so
this is basically just a uh
a reviews the starting page for reviews
for this peony
solid state drive
and there are
this is the this is the breakdown of the
cost for the
the cloud scraper as i mentioned the
browser's free
but then they have four different tiers
the project here fifty dollars a month
professional tier 100
a month business tier 200 and scale 300
so at first glance it seems like there's
some pretty good
options that are not that expensive
but there's some problems with it the
project
tier doesn't allow api access so that
was out for me
the professional is a hundred dollars a
month and
it allows api access and proxy manager
but you only get 20
000 page credits per month the business
is the everything offered with a
professional but you get 50 000 credits
and then the scale version which is 300
has unlimited page credits but there's
no proxy manager
and i'll get into the proxy manager a
little bit later on here
and again these were the primary reasons
that i needed to access the apa
api i've mentioned most of these but
there's this job completed notification
and i'm going to talk more about that
when i when i talk about the azure
function um but basically what it is is
whenever a scraping job completed
the api would send out a http
post request to a
pre-configured endpoint url and letting
letting me know that the job had had
completed
um so getting into the azure services
first i'll talk a little bit about the
data lake the most
significant folders in the data lake are
the were just uh
i had a products folder a job completed
folder raw data folder and a final json
folder
and the project product folder just held
the original csv
file with the list of product urls that
could be updated
and then the jobs completed folder
that's where i stored uh
information about the jobs that had had
completed um
in the form of a blob and
so basically that would have like the
scraping id scraping
job id stored in it so i would know that
i needed to go download that data
and then there was a folder for the raw
data
once i downloaded it from the scraper
and the json folder is just where
the final json output of the entire
collection was kept
so with the azure server serverless
function app
um again this was for the job completed
notifications
uh from the web scrapers api
for for this endpoint that i needed to
configure i used this app
and the functions function apps url
effectively served as the endpoint url
the function would be triggered whenever
a post notification was received
and then i would parse the request body
and extract the scraping job id in the
site map
and then write that to a blob and
and i could i could check that folder
with the blobs later
and download the data there are some
issues though when
dealing with python functions in uh
or writing uh azure functions with
python
the reality is that azure being
microsoft product
naturally it's it's offering more
support for
c-sharp and net platforms and
as a result the documentation for using
python
was sometimes slim compared to c sharp
this also meant that i couldn't always
do things the way i wanted i had to
make some changes here and there to my
plan on the on the go
for example i originally wanted to
download the data right there within the
same function
[Music]
turns out this wasn't possible i was
hoping that
when that when the uh job completed
notification came in
i could uh then right there send the get
request back
and and get that data but there's some
problems with um
with bindings which allow the the
function to communicate with other
services
um and the http
trigger function allowed an http post
binding
uh set to end and an http response
binding to be set to out
and it allowed for other bindings but it
wouldn't allow me to add a
second http uh binding for that get
response
that i wanted it would require a second
function
and unfortunately you can't call a
function from within an azure function
so i had to create a workaround for this
and i decided i would just update
the database so that i could later query
it to find out
um if there were any jobs that had been
completed and ready for downloading
but again another problem for some
reason azure does not support a python
binding
for azure sql database
there's one for cosmos db but not sql
server which i thought was weird
but i should mention that it is in fact
possible to write directly to sql
database from a function written in c
sharp
that is supported my work around for
this was to use this blob
binding so i could uh create a new blob
for each completed job
and it would contain the parsed
information sitemap id and all that
and i can later pull that another
frustration that i had with the python
functions
was that uh writing and editing the code
was not supported
inside the azure portal uh
within azure all the service services
exist
within that in my case they all exist
within one resource group and it has to
all use the same platform and since i
wanted to use python
it had to be a linux consumption
platform
and uh that meant
that in order to write python code for
these functions i had to do it within a
visual studio code and you know i
i kind of liked writing it in visual
studio code because there's some great
extensions for azure
in vsc but
ultimately what it meant due to the
nature of the
the uh function i was writing i couldn't
test it from vsc
i had to deploy it to azure
see if it worked and then i'd have to go
back change something deploy it azure
again
see if it worked rinse lather repeat
so this took up a lot of time um
because i was i was really new to azure
in writing these functions and with the
limited documentation
it was a lot of trial and error um so it
took up more time
than i expected with all the deployments
that i wound up having to make and this
is the actual function it's really
quite simple uh but this is the view
in vsc so it basically just takes in a
uh
takes in this request and parses it to
get the uh
to get the scraping job id and uh
site map id uh
there was one other issue that
developed at this point when i was
trying to do this
write this and what i was supposed to be
getting from
the web scraper was a request body
in json format and it was actually
not truly in a json format it was more
like a url
type notation so it would be like
scraping job id
equals three four six five and then the
ampersand sign
site map id equals 123.
so it took me a while to figure out that
that was what was causing my problems so
again having to deploy it and then run
it
it just took a lot of time so it wasn't
um
the easiest thing to do or at least
time-wise
and here's just the setup of the
bindings you can just see the three
bindings i have here there's
the http trigger for n and the blob
and the http out
so that azure data factory this is where
all of the pipelines exist
and and were coordinated i had four main
groups of pipelines
each group can usually contain two
pipelines
one of them performed all the primary
functions and the other one was
basically just
set to trigger by a scheduler and all it
did was check to see if there was any
work that needed to be done so it was
the the one
that would be polling say the uh url
list to see if any new urls had been
added or
pulling the the completed jobs blobs to
see if any
blobs were there um it would do that and
if there were if there was some work
it would then uh execute the other
pipeline the primary pipeline
so there's two versions of data factory
the version one and version two um
version two basically operates the same
way as version one except
there's an ide which makes building the
pipelines
incredibly fast and easy
the json is still working in the
background and it's just a click away
though
in version two you can toggle back and
forth from the ide to the code
view and and looking at the code view
was often helpful
for me since you know i was learning
this
i didn't always know what all the
options were and with the ide you have
to click through all the
the windows and try to find every every
available option
so that you can just figure out what's
possible but taking a quick look at the
code you could see all of the
all of the um options
there was one drawback with working with
this
second version though and and that's
that is still being developed
um it was not uncommon for me to have
finally figured something out and i go
to bed i'd wake up the next morning and
find the options had
been completely moved around and in some
cases seemingly gone
and i'd have to spend the next morning
familiarizing myself with it
with the new layout so another time
issue there
one of the things i really love about
the data factory is the ability to
create this dynamic content
so i could utilize variables and
pipeline parameters
by writing expressions
to do this so it's a bit of a learning
curve for me on this
uh learning this expression language but
but most of the functions at first
you could just click them in the ide and
it would create the expression for you
and this is primarily how i learned the
language
and eventually i found it easier just
type the expressions rather than
doing all the searching through drop
down menus to find a function
there was one strange quirk though when
it came to
variables in the data factory
while parameters could be of types
string int array bool and object
variables would only support string bool
and array
types no integer type so a lot of times
this meant i had the right expressions
that would convert
into strings when i was just just to set
the variable
and then when i wanted to use that
variable i'd have to convert
the value of the variable back into an
int
when i was using it in some dynamic
content somewhere
and the last point i wanted to mention
about the data factory is regarding the
file types and this is just
something i dealt with early on i was i
was in the learning process
so i wasn't sure whether it was better
to work with csv or json file types
so my final system wound up being a mix
of
both csv and json data sets
because at first i liked working with
the csvs but
really that was only because i hadn't
really figured out how to
the the language for uh working with the
json file
types yet
[Music]
the csvs wound up causing me to have to
do a lot more
manual configuration particularly
regarding the uh
column names and and mapping schema
things like that
some csv files use the first row as a
header and others didn't
so when when it didn't use the header as
a uh
as a uh the first row as a header i i'd
have to
you know go in and find out uh the index
of
particular columns to know what i needed
to uh
to put into my expression and this was
never an issue with json
you know with this key value pair so
once i figured json out
that's all i wanted to use if i were to
rebuild this i would i would definitely
work with json file types only if i
if i can get away with it
it's just much easier
so the basic components in the data
factory the pipelines
um you can create as many as you want
it's pretty cool because you can call
other pipelines from
within a pipeline so when i was building
the system at one point i think i had
like
17 different pipelines i was i was
treating them like
functions in in python i guess i did it
this way because it made debugging
much simpler being able to test the
small components of the design
individually and once i had all the
working components i actually started
combining them into larger pipelines
and ultimately i think i wound up with
seven pipelines in the final design
the data sets are basically just the
instructions for the file or data being
used in the data factory activity
um you need usually you need two for
most activities one for the source data
and one for the target or sync data
it basically just describes the details
of the data like where it's located and
what link service is being used um
and the format of the files the schema
etc
the link service is what allows data
factory
to access other azure services this is
where all the
things like the permissions are set up
so for example i needed a link service
for azure sql database and i need
another one for azure data lake
i needed a rest link service that
actually linked
to uh to the web scrapers api
to retrieve the data and there's quite a
few different
activities to select from depending on
what you want to do
with or to the data one of the most
common activities is the the
copy activity which um basically allows
you to move the data around
and here's kind of the anatomy of the
data factory copy activity
uh it's basically if you see here this
would be the
file in the data lake and this would be
the a table in sql server
um and so you have these data this data
set that basically
gives me all the instructions of what
this file is
and it includes the link service so the
copy activity can take
that file and extract the information
and then map it to the uh
sync data set which is the review
stagings
in a sql formatted and the links has the
link service to the database
and basically when this is triggered
it just copies everything from that file
into this review staging table
fairly fairly quickly
and with this i'll show you actually
what that would look like in data
factory uh so
here basically this is just a just
getting out of that activity it's just
grabbing all the file names
within the folder and then
this for each activity is creating an
array of those file names
this is where the magic happens uh it
iterates over that array and for each
file name
it basically sets it sets the file name
to a variable
and then there here's the copy activity
so this is what i was just describing uh
so you have the source
and there's the the data set
it's json and here's where it's located
and you can see the link service here
that that allows access
and then you have the sync data set
same deal but then the mapping
this is where you can you can mess with
it a little bit
so if i wanted to get rid of some
columns i could do that here
or if i wanted to map things to
different columns i could switch all
that
i can map it to columns that are not the
same name
so a little bit of a functionality there
and then basically after that i won't
get into the rest of this this calls a
stored procedure in the database that
actually
does all the work from that review
staging table
and does all the conversions and
cleaning the data
so go back
um so next
my original plan was not to use that
review staging so what i just showed you
that's actually
what i wound up doing but i want to tell
you now what my original plan was
and that was to utilize a mapping data
flow activity within the data factory
for cleaning converting the data before
loading it into the database
um it's really kind of neat you can
easily configure
transformations using the built-in
ide and if it doesn't have exactly what
you need then you can write a more
complex
expression uh the expression language is
not the same as
the expressions used in the for dynamic
content in the data factory
but if you're familiar with m code power
query it's
it's not an issue at all i did encounter
some issues though
when i started trying to use this
mapping data flow activity
i was able to do the conversions and
things like that but what i wanted to do
was
was insert the data into the uh
into a product table a a reviewer table
and a review table
um all from the mapping data flow and
it wound up uh
taking a long time it was a bit
challenging and and it was unusually
slow
which costs money um
and i want to talk about that uh now but
i wanted to pull this uh
data model up just so you can reference
don't worry about the two tables up in
the upper left they're just uh
they're not really a part of the final
output
so really what we have is the product
table the reviewer table in the review
table so what i had to do was first
insert
you know into the product table so i
could get that product id
and then for each record in that in that
file
i would have to insert into a reviewer
get the reviewer id
and then put insert the review into the
review
table um and once i got everything
set up in the map and data flow and i'm
ready to test
i decide i'll just use a sample of a
thousand reviews
and it runs and it runs and it runs
400 reviews and several hours later i
boarded the test
so the problem was that for each action
uh like inserting into the reviewer
table
it was opening another runtime session
costing 25 cents
per hour per view and
the other issue was that these sessions
were starting to pile up
and and some would be inactive for up to
four minutes
apparently azure considers a four minute
four minutes to be the maximum uh
cut off for what's considered normal
behavior
so i i go and i check my account and
i've spent way too much money for the
for just 400 reviews it was actually a
little over fifty dollars at that point
so that was just not reasonable so i
clearly it wasn't working and i had to
rethink things
so to quote jimmy carter if it ain't
broke don't fix it
so i decided uh scrapped the whole idea
of using mapping data flows
and i went back to good old-fashioned
sequel to do the heavy lifting
um what this meant was i would do all
the parsing converting cleaning
of the data um with sql expressions at
the same time i'm inserting it into
the database and i just used that copy
activity that i was just describing
to copy uh all of the reviews for a
single product into
a staging table and then i'd run the
stored procedure that would
take care of all the conversions and
insert it
and you know it was more work up front
but when i ran my first test the time
went from hours to just
mere seconds much more efficient
and i'd like to show you the uh stored
procedure
but before i do that i just want to
give you an idea of what the data looks
like when it comes in raw
this is actually a single record um
that's pulled from the raw data straight
from the web scraper
i'm not going to go through all this but
i just highlighted a few things just to
show you what i needed to do
just a couple of things i needed to do
so the web scraper start ul
url that's actually that url that's from
the csv
um i needed to parse that to get the
name of the product
and get the in that was one of the
things i had to do
another example is this reviewer ranking
[Music]
it's not as useful this way it's a
string
so i wanted to remove that leading pound
sign and get rid of the commas and turn
this into an
int um the idea here though was to not
lose any data so i didn't do away with
the string
that's not the plan so what i did was
create another
field a second field that held the end
and i had to do the same thing with like
review stars here and the helpful string
so this was this is just an idea of what
some of the things i had to uh do a lot
as far as conversions
here's the uh stored procedure that i
actually wrote
um and i'm not going to go through it i
just wanted to kind of give you an idea
here this is what i had to do to parse
the
product information out and then
it would get the product id and i'd
insert into the reviewer
and here's an idea of some of the the
expressions i had to
to come up with um it's not too bad but
it did take a
little bit more time than it then it
would take using a mapping data flow
but it turns out to be way more
efficient
i mean the last thing the the store
procedure does is it deletes everything
from the review staging table
after it's been inserted into the other
tables
so that way it's it's basically ready to
go into the next iteration of the
file names and repeat the process
in that data pipeline
get that out of here
so here's the here's the data once it's
in the uh database
so you can see i have a new field here
review stars and it's just an integer
five
helpful count integer one and you can
see i still have that stars
string uh in there and the review
helpful string still there
so i'm not losing any data that's that's
what was really important with this was
the idea of not
losing data not changing the data in any
way
other than cleaning it up and providing
additional fields with that clean data
and this is the data as the same record
extracted from the
same record extracted from the uh
final json out output this is this
product is hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy
i'll tell you a quick story there one of
the
when i when i was downloading all the
data and it were
loading it into the database and i was
deleting it during during all the
development
my product id number kept getting higher
and higher and higher
and when i got ready to run the final
output or the final production run
it was actually pretty close to where
the product id
um for hitchhikers got in the galaxy was
gonna be 42
and i was really hoping that it would be
but it wound up being 47 or 48
i'm a huge hitchhiker's guided galaxy
fan if
you didn't figure that out
back to the web scraper i want to dig a
little just a little bit deeper into
this
um so first and foremost with some of
the problems that
it's it's kind of expensive i needed
that access
you know at the very minimum i needed
that hundred dollars a month for
development
20 000 credits were enough for the
development phase
but the idea was that i would upgrade to
the scale version once i was ready for
the production run
um this would give me unlimited page
credits but it cost 300 for that
month and i would only need it for a
month but
quite a jump in the price what i didn't
realize
at that point in time was that the skill
version did not include the proxy
manager
i haven't talked about that yet so i
want to get into that
basically what the proxy manager does is
it rotates through different ip
addresses during the scraping
helps to avoid the bot detection which
is absolutely necessary
if you're trying to scrape data from
amazon they're pretty you're on top of
that
so the scale subscription didn't have
this option but it
did offer an option to add a custom
proxy via a third-party provider of your
choice
um at this point i was running out of
time i had just days to finish this
project
so i didn't dig too deep into this all i
knew was that was an added cost
which was something i was not interested
in at that point
um so i i can't i wound up using the
business subscription
um which came with the proxy manager and
50 000
page credits which was enough for me i
was only interested in scraping 15
products
just to demonstrate that this system
worked
um but this is clearly not a big data
solution where scalability is necessary
that's that's the main problem
[Music]
so you know going with the business
subscription it worked for me
but you know it it's it's just not
it's just not feasible um the last
problem with the cloud scraper
was that uh it didn't always perform as
expected
you know i never had this problem using
just the route the web browser the free
version but
sometimes the cloud scraper it would it
would finish scraping a product and fail
to send that job completed notification
and other times it would stop a scraping
job and never restart
um with all this combined it just made
the cloud-based scraper not a feasible
feasible uh
thing to use uh the return just didn't
justify the investment
by the time the project ended i had
spent 600
on the web scraper and i only had i had
a little over 17
000 records from the 15 products
so alternatives obviously
it got me thinking what are some
alternatives to this and you know at
first i was thinking
well i could utilize a virtual compute
environment and run
some kind of script that that hacks sort
of hacks the free browser extension
version
um but
this this really isn't the best idea in
my opinion uh
i think it would be better to create the
web scraper
uh and you know there's
python libraries for this very purpose
uh
like scrapy uh selenium
and beautiful soup i haven't really
spent a lot of time
researching what's out there but i'm
sure some of you might have some input
and i'd love to hear your thoughts on
on some of the available python
libraries that are out there
so summing up things the data factory is
it's a great tool
um but keep in mind that version 2 is
still being developed
the documentation is kind of slim in
some areas
so i had to do a lot of my own research
i would occasionally
find a youtube video that could guide me
in the right direction but
i rarely found examples that that fit
exactly
what i was trying to do but i'd get a
little piece from one video i'd get
another piece from a second video and so
on
and then there's the data type issue
with the variables i
i don't really get it it it seems like
an oversight
but i'm sure microsoft has a perfectly
fine explanation as to why you can't
have a variable of type
it i just haven't been able to find it
yet
and i don't want to sound like i don't
like the data factory because that's
it couldn't be more the opposite i
absolutely fell in love with the data
factory
it was it was slow at first while i was
trying to figure everything out
like how to utilize the dynamic content
with with the expressions
um but now i can quickly build complex
python
pipelines with very little effort using
the data factory
and i also don't want to completely test
the mapping data flow component because
i do think that it's a great tool for
easily designing
scalable etl or elt processes
it just wasn't the right fit for what i
was trying to do
with the lack of support for loading the
sql databases
sql database it was just very
frustrating slow
costly the hundreds of stagnated
stagnating open sessions were just too
inefficient
while it did take a little bit more time
up front doing this with sql
it was much more efficient and less
costly in the long run
now with azure serverless functions
more support for python is something
that i really hope microsoft is working
on
they're constantly rolling out new
things so i'm hoping that's
that's common it was frustrating because
i
i'd read a lot of the documentation
early on when i was planning my design
so for example i i thought that it would
be possible to make an insertion into
the database
from the function um and the reality is
you actually can just not with python
with
azure lacking that sql database binding
but dot net platform using c c sharp no
problem
um and the other problem with python is
not being able to write
uh or test the python code within the
azure
portal i spent a lot of time debugging
having to deploy the code
every time i made a change in order just
to test it
as for the web scraper you know as i was
just saying
it the cloud version of the web scraper
is just not worth the money
in my opinion for this kind of job
the browser's extension is really great
for
quickly creating you know custom scrape
jobs and i think that's pretty cool
but if if you need a scalable or
automated solution
i feel that cloud version is is just not
the best option
just too costly and it doesn't always
perform as expected
i think building a custom scraper using
python
way much better uh solution i'm planning
on trying that
in the future in my spare time
um that's a really all i have unless you
have any immediate questions
for me right now um because if not i'm
going to turn things back over to
leo uh there's my email
but you can you can also find me on
linkedin and i'm going to post a chat
with my email and linkedin url along
with the url that links to my paper for
this project
hey ryan we have a couple questions in
the chat from mark
so one is have you looked at other web
scraping services
see i really didn't do a whole lot of
research i did
a little bit but i didn't do a whole lot
because that was one of the
requirements going into this project was
that i used this third party
web scraper that they were already
working with so
it wasn't an option for me to change it
but at this point in time
that is where i'm i'm leaning in my
spare time i'm hoping to kind of dig in
and do some research
and see if there's something more
feasible
not quite as costly sounds good and kind
of on
along the same lines um have you used or
have you looked into
selenium to implement automation
selenium was one of the things one of
the ones that i uh
i found when it came to uh you know the
scraper and and i did read about that
you know i started realizing that that
was something that i could use
as far as this ottoman auto nation goes
and so i i'm really interested with
selenium
uh and like i said earlier i'm i'm
looking forward to hearing any feedback
that if anyone
you know has worked with any of these
and i could possibly provide me
that would be great
awesome well yeah those are the
questions in the chat yeah ryan
ryan uh this isn't really a question as
much as a statement that microsoft got
serious last year uh about supporting
python when it hot
when it hired guido van rossum
but it it as with most things it's just
going to take a while for
for for that implementation to to fan
out into the
the azure data factory right see i
noticed that a lot of
a lot of the support was really new
um when i started you know researching
this back in september
uh a lot i noticed that they were really
working on it
trying to to provide more support for
python
so that's why i was really hoping that
you know it's heading in the right
direction with that
so that's good to hear
and chuck uh check the chat log chuck
just posted something about
uh scraping from within amazon
within amazon i think
scraping something let me see what's
where is my everything moved around on
me now i'm trying here it is
uh possibly use blog
entry if you weren't forced to use the
scraper
you mentioned huh api tutorials okay
um
i am definitely going to look into that
uh
that looks pretty cool i appreciate that
any other questions or comments
slap that bass i'm always doing
that
all right i'll stop sharing here
yeah it looks like we're a little early
on time so leo
feel free to go into more detail or we
can end earlier
all right can i go ahead and share my
screen
yes
do you see my screen yep
all right awesome so hello again
um before i go into the presentation
let me say that a lot of my students
complain about
me going really fast
so if i ever go too fast please feel
free to
uh send a message in the chats asking
for
a slower slowdown
but i'll try to be careful with that
and with that let's go back to
the project so with this project you're
trying to
select number of reviews that will
represent the overall corpus
the best now best
is not really clearly defined
so let's talk about the metrics
and the metrics we have is the total
number of words
in the subset this subset can have one
review
two review three review in terms of
our project but there is no limit to um
nsx overviews
the second uh criteria we have
is number of reviews in the subset so
better
it has one review two review or three
reviews since you're trying to minimize
it
uh in a in a in a
optimal situation it would be less
reviews
uh and then distance between subset and
the corpus
this is um a i will go into more detail
how to calculate the distance but it's
basically hubs
calculation of how similar the review
subset
we chose to the corpus
which is the overall of the reviews
and then finally content coverage
this is about the subset covering
at least minimum amount of certain
content
from the corpus
now in klein's paper he breaks down the
optimization models into two groups
the first one is reading minimizing
here in this matrix we have four
cells the first one is number of
documents
what we are trying to do here is trying
to minimize the number of documents
while it's subject to different criteria
so the first one would be trying to
minimize the number of documents
that's subject to the content level
that will be the minimum threshold
and then number of documents with a
maximum distance subject so
we would try to minimize the number of
documents
which meets the uh distance threshold
uh at the bottom we have the number of
terms words used
uh in this one we are trying to
minimize the words i'm sorry in the
upper layer it was actually number of
documents which is number of reviews
so we're trying to minimize the reviews
whereas
uh on the second row it's number of
terms
in the subset once again we have two
constraints subject to the content level
and subject to maximum distance
so these are our the reading
minimization
uh models
and then we have the content maximizing
here we have two constraints it's the
number of documents and number of words
we are trying to minimize the distance
while
having a threshold on number of
documents
so for example if we would like to see
at most two documents two reviews
which one would have the smallest
distance
from the corpus and then the second
constraint instead of documents we have
number of words
we will have for instance 400 words
limit on the subset of reviews
we pick and with that constraint we will
try to minimize the distance
any question about the models
okay now to
calculate the distance we
somehow need to convert this text data
into
a numerical value to calculate the
distance
so there is a known
concept called document term frequency
matrix
which lists the documents and the terms
or in other words
the words in them and the document term
frequency matrix
can be in different forms there's binary
bag of words or document term frequency
matrix there's non-binary
and n-grams
here as an example i have three small
sentences and if you were to look at the
document term frequency matrix for these
three documents
we would first look at the binary one
which is the top
table here we see only
ones and zeros for the terms
the terms at the top and the columns
are also will be referred as dictionary
later on so these are all of the unique
terms in my set of documents
and for each document whether it has
that word or not
i will assign a binary binary value
and this matrix will be called the
binary
document term frequency matrix or binary
bag of words
for documents whereas on the second one
we see um numbers other than ones and
zeros
uh here we actually store the actual
frequency of the term so if a
term occurs multiple times in that
document
we put the frequency to the
uh related cell
so here we see some different numbers
for documents for instance the term the
occurs two times and let's see there's
another two for document three four car
now i did not show the n grams here
but because it would not actually fit
fit to the presentation
but for this third one what we would
have is
different grams so let's say first of
all the second one we have is
a one gram uh document term frequency
matrix
if you wanted to move it to uh two grams
four columns we would have the
combinations of words
so the first column could be the car
and then car was was going
so and so forth and then based on the
frequency
it would uh create the document term
frequency matrix
now with 2 grams there is this
catch it could be up to 2 grams or
2 grams if it is up to 2 grams
then you would include the one gram one
so you would have the
car was as separate columns
than the two gram versions and if you
went to
three grams then you would have three
terms adjacent terms combined and their
relative
frequency so this is how we represent a
text document in a numerical form
any questions on this
all right now here's the code i
used uh there's a common library called
uh sklearn i think actually the library
is called
scikit and sklearn is a specific
module of it here you see the count
vectorizer
here in the count vectorizer i pass uh
three different things the n low and n
high
so if i were to do one gram i'm sorry
two grams up to two grams then i would
put
n low one and n high would be two
so the end low is the bottom and and
high is the top trash
hold but none of these parameters
are um uh they're
all of them are optional none of them
are mandatory the default value for
ngram
is one gram so if you wouldn't if you
don't put anything for engram range
uh you will get one gram
document term frequency matrix the
second parameter you see there
is the stop words uh the scikit
sk learn has a built-in stop words
list and i use
that one to eliminate some stop works
now this is actually a uh important
piece of our
project we were really uh
hesitating to use stunt words because
in the nature of stop words different
libraries
have different lists of stop words there
are articles mentioning
how uh how different these different
stop words lists are different libraries
there are
over 10 that i actually found during my
research
had completely different set of words
while having some common things such as
the as and and
and words like that now
like i said we were really hesitating to
use
stop words because our goal was to make
this
uh method in a way that you can repeat
with anything now since
we are not sure what the content is a
specific stop word list
could have an important word in it that
we would
get rid of so uh an example
is for one of the products i chose from
amazon
which was a woman dress and it had a
word called a line well a
alone can be detected as stout word
but a line actually means a specific
thing
so using the stop words i would actually
lose that
which is the reason why we were
resistant but in the end
we had to use the stop words because in
our calculations
the stock words were throwing the
numbers off
they were becoming we were having a lot
of
outliers in the values in the
document term frequency matrix therefore
we decided to
uh use the stopwatch list after looking
at it and seeing that
it has a small list of stop words
and here in the documents i passed the
uh the documents the csv file
and then it does a bunch of things such
as feature names those are going to be
the columns
uh and then i to uh transfer
like to transfer to a list
and then transfer it to a data frame
that the feature names terms being the
columns
all right now let's look at
some results of the data
like i said we chose three products let
me tell you why we chose those three
products
so when we were starting this project we
realized that
the product choice would affect the
results
a lot that was our assumption because
different products
could potentially have different
vocabularies
or different styles in the
types of review for instance when a
book review can be more descriptive that
a high number of dictionary length or in
other words vocabulary
a ssd or a woman's dress could have
less or more in its vocabulary so
we specif specifically chose three
different products that we thought could
potentially show a different behavior
and we would like to catch that behavior
now looking at the first table
um you're also seeing that the minimum
number of
reviews on our products is over one
thousand
uh we chose this number to be between
one thousand and four thousand
um to first of all the eliminate the
problem of having computational limits
it would need
a threshold for maximum number of
reviews and for a lower threshold
we chose thousand because less than that
uh
would worry us about the um how
accurate would the results be uh so to
have the higher sample size
we chose 1 000 threshold
now looking at these we see that ssd has
1 000 reviews dress has almost 4 000 and
the book has
close to 2 000. looking at the average
word count of different reviews
we see that the address reviews are
tend to be or on average have less words
even though there are more reviews
while the ssd has the highest average
word count each review and book has
a close number to ssd
the second thing is max word count so
it's the uh
longest review uh this result actually
did not surprise us
we assumed the expected book reviews to
be
longer so the largest book review
was actually over 1 1300
words while the
longest dress review was 196 that's
ten times almost or seven times shorter
uh and ssd had almost a thousand
word in the longest review now in the
word count
a minimum word count you will see ones
and zero
you may think how a review can have
zero um terms
now i looked at this data specifically
and these minimum word counts
uh for specific reviews were
due to special characters they use so i
am not 100
sure if amazon is actually enforcing a
limit or like the minimum word count now
but some of these reviews had only a
smiley face with a column in a
parenthesis
and during the data cleaning process
i eliminated those
and they were left with zero terms
and then looking at the dictionary
length
we see the book has
over 7000 so book has the most
vocabulary
ssd follows it with 4700
and dress right around 4 000.
now i also would like to mention what i
did to get
these values after getting the initial
uh data from web scraper i used
microsoft power bi to clean my data
the reason why i chose microsoft uh
power bi is because it was compatible
with the tools that i was
familiar with like sql
and the second reason was that it was
producing
dax code which could be copied and
pasted
to repeat the exact same steps i
followed
if you also follow the same site map
and get exactly same data
now let me share my power bi screen
leo yes uh
on your uh your word count column that
you just showed us
what are the numbers in parentheses
following the the average word count
that's the standard deviation
thanks yeah so
let's go to power bi
thank you for that question that was a
good one
um let's change it it's not this one
right here uh
so right here i had the initial data
which uh i can just go to the
follow the steps on the right side i
have applied steps
uh if i go to the source version or
older version i see
how the data looked like so for instance
the first one
there were no column names because the
initial row or not was not recognized as
the
header row so i had that
and i had the link the url to that
specific review
i had the author information
and the title of the review
with dates and
content which is the review itself it's
some rating
and also
whether or not these reviews were
verified
um and how many helpful voters they got
now we were hoping to look at different
analysis of these reviews
so we collected things like verification
and helpful votes but we were not
uh we did not have enough time to
actually analyze that
uh however i actually have a couple of
examples
on the selected subsets uh whether or
not they were verified
i will look at them later i will show
them later
things i did on this data was pretty
simple steps
i made the first row the header i got
rid of some columns that i did not need
such as the url
um i may i change the date format to
only have um so you see that there's a
location on the date too so i got rid of
that
to just have february 28 2018
um on the rating
i had a uh text data
uh one out of five stars so i had to
convert this to an
integer if you wanted to do some
analysis so i got rid of
um the text and converted it to
integer in one of these steps here
and then got rid of the
reference and next for verification
i had to convert these to true false
binary values
for verified purchases i just set them
to true
for helpful votes it was a little weird
there were three cases it could be null
which would mean
no helpful votes if there's only one
helpful vote it would
use i would say one person found this
helpful without
actually using a numerical value
in the data that comes back but
anything greater than one would actually
have the number like here
three people found this helpful so i
also converted this to have
just a number of our null takes the
value zero
now about how we would repeat this
process
is if we follow the same site map
which i can provide it would provide us
exact same columns and
looking at my dax code right here
you could just change the document
location
and paste everything else
and that would apply all of the steps i
followed
which is what i did for other products
i just copied the steps and applied them
to
other ones
uh any question about power vips
and data cleaning piece
all right once i had the data
cleaned up i just transferred this data
into a
csv file which would be used in the code
to
create the document term frequency
matrix let's go back there
the second table here it has information
about the stopwater elimination
uh on the first column you see the total
number of
words before the stopward elimination
and
on the second one after the elimination
now you see that
um while the book data had more stop
words
there was not a significant difference
for this value across
across the corpses also i think
having this kind of result made sense
because
uh when you have a larger vocabulary
there's a higher chance of having
stoppers included in there so having 284
uh for book data did not really surprise
me
and if you look at the ssd address even
before the illumination they had
a similar number of
words in their corpses and their total
number of stop words eliminated were
also
similar
now we in the next step we
reduce the data
the main reason for this was because our
computational limits
if we go back and look at this data
you will see that dress for instance has
3797 reviews so
one grain long gram matrix
would produce a 3797 by
4000 matrix that's quite large
and for 2 gram it would go even
beyond that and the second thing
we would need to take into account was
the combinations
so if you were to look at sets of 1 sets
of 2 sets of 3 that's
n choose k problem so for dress we would
have 37 97 without any reduction
if you were to look at all combinations
of three reviews
that would be and the 37 97 choose three
and i think there are a little over nine
billion
uh combinations and for each of these
you would have to calculate the
uh distance from the corpus so it would
it was causing some serious uh
computational problems
and secondly um we also realized that
there were some outliers that we were
almost certain that would not be
included in the
um results uh so for instance if a
review has less than five words or ten
words it was really unlikely that was
our assumption
to reduce the and the dimensions
we said that if it is less than 10 then
it's probably not going to help much
now let's go back to the steps we first
eliminated stop words
then we eliminated words that do not
have enough variance which
i will go into that in a second and then
eliminate
reviews that have less than 10 words
left
and then so
at the first stage the first table right
here
has the numbers from the previous table
exactly the same numbers
and after the step one we see the term
count
is reduced that's the elimination of
stop words
now on the third one you see that the
term count
goes down drastically from seven
thousands to thirty
seventies what we did here
is we looked at the binary uh
document term frequency matrix
of all of these reviews and we chose
binary on purpose because our goal was
to see
if a word appeared in documents
all the time or not enough times so if a
term is used
only in one document on every document
there's not enough variance therefore
they would not contribute
to differentiating the review
from the corpus so
we calculated the standard deviation
uh since the values would be only one
and zero
the high standard deviation we would
have was 0.5
which in the case of having half of the
reviews having that specific term
and the remaining half not having the
term
uh and our threshold was 0.25 standard
deviation
we played with this value to look at the
term count
once again we chose this arbitrary
number
uh which is actually a something that a
future study would
should uh or would like to explore
playing with that number but our main
goal was
pulling it to the limits of our
computational resources
and then once we eliminated those
so-called uh unworthy
terms uh unworthy in the sense of not
helping
us differentiate the reviews um
we have we were left with these term
counts and
while looking at those reviews we said
well some of these
now have less than 10 words in them
and we thought once again that they
would not really
uh they did not realistically have a
chance of
ending up in the optimal solution due to
its low term count which would
result in high distance between between
the review and the corpus
so we said less than 10 words left uh
eliminate that
that brought our review count down to
between two late uh high 200s to
a mid 400s so with that we had the final
uh reduced data that we would
use in our process
any question about this data reduction
all right i was actually expecting some
questions about this piece
let's keep going now
the next thing is vector space model
so we had the reviews
represented in a numerical form
but what happens after that how do we
calculate the
distance so-called distance between
documents or
between a uh chosen document and the
overall corpus
now for that there's a known model
called vector space model
um so with this each uh
term in the corpus in the dictionary
would be a dimension so in a book's case
we would have over 7 000 dimension
before the elimination
but after the elimination we have
uh 39 dimensions
and the documents represented in
um not dotted lines would have a
position in that vector space
based on their term counts and then
using a basic euclidean distance
function
we could look at how similar these two
uh sets of documents are so here the
first one the dr is one document cs is
corpus
and then we're just taking the
difference between each dimension
and taking the score of it uh summing it
up
and taking the square root of it which
is what it would basically do
in trigonometry to find the um
what was that hypotenuse i think
that's what it's called in english so
you would just take the square
of two sides and then square root of it
you would get the hypo hypotenuse so
that's what we did for getting the
distance between them
uh now a point to make here
uh the calculation of distance
uh in that process we did not use the
original terms
uh which would make the whole reduction
process meaningless
um therefore we use the
limited terms the second thing is we
converted our vectors to unit vector
because for
high value high review ones it would
um it would actually
work in their advantage and eliminate
the low review ones
even though they capture
the content but does not have repetitive
information
so let's say the term drive
occurs a lot in the corpus
if a review has dry once it's talking
about that concept
but another review that just repeats the
term drive
would end up being in the optimal result
which
did not make sense to us so we
calculated the unit vector
now uh other than the euclidean distance
there are some other models that you can
use for
finding how similar documents are one is
cosine method
i'm not going to go into details of it
but it's available and there's another
one
which i can't recall right now
any questions about the vector space
model
uh date go ahead arty yeah i think david
asked a question in the chat
um about the metric
um the question is doesn't this metric
have a problem
with the curse of dimensionality
uh can you explain it further
hey david can you explain that in more
detail and
oh well okay oh yeah
so that's something i actually
mentioned in future research piece so
that part is called limitation so
driving drives run uh rain
or like fit and fits essentially
uh mean the same thing so to deal with
this problem there's
limitation the however did not apply
this uh apply it to this project but we
said that that would be a good um
future study because in our results we
actually saw the problems with it but
due to the limited time scope and the
resources we
did not go into that
does that make sense chuck
david can you unmute yourself
clarify your question
oh my bad it was david nostrak my bad
all right i'm just going to keep going
uh and david you can just put in chat or
in the next stop point i would gladly
answer the
question now we are getting into results
piece
now in the results i will show you
let's oh sorry i figured out my
microphone
all right so what was the question
well cursive dimensionality is where you
have
so all these dimensions you're showing
are your different keywords
basically so if you had a thousand
keywords that you retained the problem
is this
is high dimensional so everything
becomes equidistant
in high dimensional spaces with a
euclidean metric
it's like you take a imagine you take a
cube
and then you round off all the corners
because you make it more dimensional
it becomes more like a sphere oh that's
true that's true
although what would it would make a
difference with
a unit vector euclidean distance because
uh if
a if there's a drastic difference
between these reviews
you know um let's say majority of terms
used in one review or not using the
other one
uh that was our goal to catch up at this
but i
see what you're mentioning and i would
like to look
into that further
okay and then the other thing is this is
unweighted
so you have no weight all you have is
variance of each keyword
well your metric here doesn't reward a
very distinctive keyword
versus um you know variance is your only
measure well
uh it's actually it has that
because the unit vector i'm using i'm
normalizing the frequencies
i'm not using the binary here during the
calculation of distance i'm using the
actual
non-binary frequency matrix and then i'm
normalizing it so
if a term occurred 10 times and the
review itself has 1000
words in it it will be 10 over 1000 so
it would be normalized at the unit
vector
okay thanks for the answers
thank you for the questions
all right so let's look at some of the
results
before i get into results i would like
to say
i will show only two models and
towards the end i can explain why the
other models
did not work but the models i will be
showing is the reading
minimizing first and then content
maximizing
now in this one i was applying the
reading minimization
and this is the book
review the solution i found had a
distance of 07.
uh the solution was from two grams
and the document ids are listed there
actually don't make much meaning
if you don't have my thesis document but
i will show those
uh documents in the slide
comment but what we are going to look at
here is
this is a histogram of the corpus and
the chosen solution
so uh here you see the normalized
values for each term their frequency and
the
orange line represents the overall
corpus
while the lighter color represents the
chosen subset
so we see a similar behavior here now
there are two things here one you see
that the book
the word book itself has this high value
that throws things off now that relates
back to the
stuff works we could simply
manually add the term book
into our stock works but then it would
not be
automated we would have to create a
different list of stop words
each time um the second thing is we were
actually hoping to
get rid of words such as book that
the data reduction piece because if it
is
that frequent overall uh we thought it
would get
removed but it ended up being right
below the
threshold uh so right above the
threshold so we kept the term book
and on the light line uh you see that
there are jumps and it's due to just
occurrence of the occurrence of the word
once or
zero you see a smaller line for the
corpus because
each term occurs at least once
right or if the terms are eliminated and
not left then
it wouldn't be there but for um
for the chosen subset you will see jumps
from one to zero
so one is four and then when it occurred
only one times and then it didn't occur
but uh the important point is that they
share
the worthy terms uh
so-called worthy terms that we found
and the reviews
for those three
uh for that product book product
are here uh can you
read the screen i don't know if you guys
would like
to read it but there are some points
that i will make
is there can you read it
yeah i was worried that it was too small
but uh looking at here uh actually
a couple of things i notice one is
if you look at the first and the second
review
you see quite positive things uh whereas
on the third one
it's a negative review and
uh that tells us this method actually
i mean this was an expected thing
because we did not do any semantic
analysis
but uh we did not really expect to have
um this much of difference between the
selected ones but it makes sense as it
covers both
positive and negative sides of the
product perhaps
but once again this was an exploratory
thing so we just
tried to look at how it behaves and for
book review this
is how it behaved so
in addition to the histogram we also
created a word cloud
and on the left hand side we have the
corpus and on the right side we have
the um the subset of reviews
um and between these word clouds
um at least for me there's a high
similarity so the terms used most
are shared between the corpus and
the um subset in terms of
weighted frequency the other thing
is just like in histogram you see the
term book
takes a lot of space and it is probably
as an outlier affecting the other ones
so uh that is something i would like to
look at in the future
any opinion any question about these
work clouds
all right so um
leo leo a quick ques a quick question uh
what was the
what was the run time to find
these three to match up or extract or
identify these three okay
so let me tell you about that first of
all
we calculated this for one gram two gram
and three gram
as well as sets of one sets of two and
sets at three
so for uh each of those uh situations we
had
different uh values and i think i have
a document i kept the times for it but
off the top of my head i can tell you
the longest one was two hours ish
um and that was a three grand
um and sets of three
while the uh one or two gram and sets of
one and two
were almost instant or like a couple
seconds
so it was mainly the sets of three um
that started increasing it a lot and i
would run out of
uh memory and i started to solve that
problem i just uh
dumped every once in a while the data uh
and write it to the drive
and then after throwing it that would
save up some space in the memory and
keep going like that
and i think i did that with every five
hundred thousand combination after every
five hundred thousand i
throw away that data or in other words
dumped it into the hard drive
and then ran it um most of the
time was spent on actual calculation of
distance
other things in the app um not in the
app but in the code did not really take
that long
and i'm not sure if it's the most
optimal code
uh but let me show you the code
if you have time let me see oh
maybe i should keep going and then if
you have time we can go back
because there's still a good bit of
stuff
now uh what i'm going to
show tell you about these is first thing
we notice
is uh we almost
never got a not almost actually we never
got a
uh subset with one review or two review
so in other words no one review or two
review
uh represent the overall corpus doesn't
matter how many words in it
as well as a combination of reviews
which makes sense because different
reviews are actually captured
different points made in the corpus
uh the second thing we notice is the
anagram none of the solutions
uh actually provided a
um three gram solution
and that is because
let me um
you if it was here
uh i don't have it here but i can tell
you that between two grams and three
grams
no uh different terms survive the
data reduction so from 1 gram to 2 gram
we had different terms that survived but
from 2 gram to 3 gram
we did not any new terms
surviving the data reduction now that
perhaps makes sense because there are
less uh combination of three words
uh you know in english or any other in
any other language the most common ones
will be
one or two words with a different
meaning you know
to have have to but
the combinations of three words is not
as
common so that's why it did not survive
in
our project that's my assumption and i
actually
checked it with some data and it was
proving that
any questions
okay i have the reviews for these two
oh my god let me go here so you see this
one chose
engram two um it was not as close
in this one you can see the distance is
higher
overall in the hard drive the ssd
data set i saw um that the minimum
distance
was a lot higher so
not even the best solution among
our reduced data set we when we did the
brute force we couldn't find anything as
close as
other corpses
and then the solution we have here is n
gram two
and let's see
oh i forgot to mention the constraints
on this
i calculated these values and found the
solutions on sql
once all of the combinations were
created and
dumped in the csv format i imported that
data into a
sql database and ran bunch of queries
with
in this one for instance i had a
subject to distance so there was a max
level of distance that i put which was
0.1
uh and then i try to minimize the
term count and
i have different tables showing the
total word count of
this but among the ones that uh
less than the distance threshold
the best solution was this one with the
uh lowest term cap now
obviously i could choose another optimal
solution
but this is a dual problem where uh
basically it's
it's like um supply and demand so
um when one increases often times the
other one decreases so
when the term count increases then the
distance gets smaller
now um on that side
i created actually all the possible
solutions and i showed them in my thesis
these are just some examples i paid
but for all of those values if you would
like to see the top 10 for instance and
choose your own
so-called optimal because it's actually
based on what you want to read
a person can say i want to read at most
200 words or 400 words
so if you want to look at the top 10
you can refer to my thesis which i can
share a link to
and as time gets close i'm going to
go a little faster here these are the
word clouds
between the corpus and the chosen subset
for the ssd product
we see similar words uh
now it is once again not as close as the
other one while we see
uh some uh common things you know like
drive crucial
i believe the macbook occurs a couple
times
right here we don't see as good of a
result
as the book one and it confirms with the
distance because the book uh product
the optimal solution i chose was had a
distance of 0.73
while this one has over 0.9
any questions
all right so uh then we have the
uh we have the uh the dress
products and for this one
we also got a three review subset
uh as the optimal solution and even in
top
50 we had no single or two review
subsets
to get into the uh subject to distance
that we chose which is an arbitrary
number
in terms of how how many words or how
close
we want it to be which could be adjusted
with
any uh anyone who wants to apply this
uh we see a similar behavior i'm not
going too much into detail with it
i can tell you the difference between
the uh
book and the other two in the book
we had two positive one negative review
whereas
in the ssd and address
all three reviews are positive and when
i looked at the overall rating
i actually saw a high rate of
positive reviews in these reviews in
these products
so perhaps that makes sense
once again we look at the word
cloud and like one of you mentioned
before the lemmatization becomes an
issue you see the fit here
so there's fit but there's also fits so
if you were
if you would lemmatize it and consider
them as
uh same meaning words then the numbers
would
change a lot but like i said that was
for another study
and now i have the results for
content maximizing in this one
my goal was putting a subject word count
and less than a word count and i was
trying to
minimize the distance which would
maximize the content
um and in all of the solutions here
um once again we didn't see anything
from three gram options and we did not
see anything from
two review or one review subset
now the other strange thing was both for
content maximizing
and
reading minimization they actually got
the same solution
same set of reviews so if you look at
the reduce
rating minimization for book
you see these three reviews
these are the same ones that came out
from
the content maximizing
right here so i did not share the review
again now this
occurred for two products both for book
and ssd the result i'm sorry for book
and dress the results were same from the
two models
whereas for uh for the ssd we had a
better
solution and content maximizing
but it did not actually make a huge
difference
since it was a content maximize
maximization and we were trying to
reduce the distance
the difference between those two
solutions in the different models
was less than 0.003 so the other one if
the other one was 0.075 this one was
0.072 so the this
the difference was not a lot so uh
overall
i can say both of these models uh
produce similar results very similar
results
uh and it is because like i said it's a
dual problem so
if you look at from cost uh and
um i'm sorry supply and demand you'll
reach the same result when
supply increases uh the demand
decreases or vice versa
and let's keep skip these
because once again they're the same word
clouds that's what i'm
why i'm not showing
in the discussion let's see
now let me go back and tell you why the
content that the other models did not
work and how they
could actually work let's look at this
one
so on the minimization side we see
number of documents and number of
terms because we could only do such
subsets of three and just to mention
this if i went to
subsets of four for let's say four
thousand reviews without any reduction
that would be trillions uh and for
five it will be even greater our initial
goal was to go
up to four or five to find that sweet
spot
but we had to stop at three because of
the computer limits we had now the uh
issue with number of documents was
since we chose only up to three 33
percent of it was
one review sets 33 percent uh the tour
review so and so forth
so there is not enough um diversity so
the solution you would choose for um
minimization of the documents and you
choose
one review subsets there's no difference
between those 33 percent
it was not differentiating enough to
pick one every time you run it you can
get a different result
therefore the document uh number of
documents reduction
was not valid now that being said i
think if he went to five or six
we could have actually see a bigger
difference but we would
again have the issue of
running the same query but getting
different result all the time
and from here
i'm sorry the content chart
documents maximum distance
oh same same thing here the number of
documents
that got eliminated and this one got
picked but
uh let me go in here why the content
level did not work
so obviously i explained number of
documents so the top row did not work
this is the first one reading
minimization that i showed
which worked and this one we could not
apply because of
this reason so for a number of
terms and the content level the approach
we took was
we looked at the uh weighted frequency
of the corpus and we said let's say
let's look at a combination of reviews
that have
at least let's say one percent
of what the corpus has for that term
and the remaining ones not the seven
thousand
but uh in most cases
uh only one or two survived for book but
for other products
none of them survived so perhaps having
a
content level in that sense was not a
good idea
or if we had five reviews
we could perhaps have candidates that
meet that requirement but even the
minimum
requirement was not met by any subsets
of reviews
so therefore this one got eliminated
so from this four uh different models
the bottom right is what worked and from
the second one
is the number of words constrained with
the minimized distance that worked
and the number of documents was not
successful
any questions on that why we eliminated
why those did not work any suggestion
why it did not work opinions
i have a different question about the
the number of documents that you were
processing
uh for ssd and dress
could you go back to those counts uh
after reduction
no no but uh yeah that one they
you were there just a moment ago okay um
yeah so
you had you had starting out uh 7 300
for book
and about 47 or 4 000 for
ssd and dress but in a later slide
you talked about um a tuple that's
a tuple that showed up in terms of
similar documents
that had the same number and i think for
the ssd or the dress
the document id was higher than
4762 and so i was wondering
how do you get a document id that was
greater than the the number of documents
that you have
uh so uh here i'm only showing
one grams uh actually for two grams and
three grams these would be different
because in the three grams there are
more terms than what you see here so for
instance for ssd i believe there were
72 okay therefore the number of reviews
survived changed as well okay
um also when when doing some rand
random uh random choices um
a seed a seed is either defaulted or
selected
and i'm wondering if if you might have
uh gotten a seed reuse
between your runs
oh yeah that that could be why
but also so if you think about it uh
when your force is looking less than
two reviews you're left with 33
of the data it's not it's not a good
threshold
it's not helping you pick the best one
because
you'll be left with so many options if
that's the only criteria for
optimization
which is what was described in those two
models in client's paper
right it just it just occurred to me
that
if you've got the same the the same
documents
that were paired up that in two
different review sets
that perhaps you're there was a random
number
uh seed that was being used
that caused the same documents to be
matched
to be matched up and you're just getting
the best of those sets
yeah oh i see what you're saying between
the two models reading minimization and
the
content maximization yeah okay
from later from later on when you're
describing um
the documents the the reviews that you
showed us for
ss for either ssd or dress um
and up the top you've you've got which
doc
which reviews they were and you noted
when you when you showed us the those
slides that uh
uh not i i don't think it's this one but
it's another one that had like 6 000
that that those
those three were the same as different
reviews like
this one which is the same as the uh
content maximization one we get this
exact same set is that what you're
saying
yeah yeah exactly that's what we noticed
are uh
the way we interpreted it is because
the both models essentially looked at
the same
dual problem you know there was no
um third thing to look at when
the number of words decreased generally
uh
the distance increased so
uh when we chose similar thresholds we
got similar results
in those two
not sure if that makes sense
so essentially we're saying that both of
these models will produce
similar results if not the same
based on the approach we took so
if we change the dimension reduction
process
we may see something different if we did
limitization
we could see something different
if we uh tried different sets of reviews
we could see something different
now let's look at the other points as
i'm
slowly running out of time
i already mentioned most of these i said
limitization would be a good uh future
research thing stop words
i don't know if there's a good way of
creating or
automating the stop word creation for
different sets
so if i could create a list of stop
words
uh from scratch based on the product
itself
uh that would be an interesting thing
so that way we would get rid of for
instance book or
drive because obviously book doesn't
make
it make a lot of sense to uh
take into consideration for
differentiating reviews because
it's about a book the product itself is
a book
so uh i'm curious if anybody has an idea
about
generation of stop words um based on the
document
and doing it in an automatic repeatable
sense
but i was not able to find anything
uh and with engram i already mentioned
this before i think
uh once again it it might
we might get different result with a
different data set which is why
i provided all my code to be able to
repeat this
with different products uh we can see a
different result but based on this
research
three gram was pointless and it just
increased the computation time
because there was no difference between
the
a dictionary after a dimension reduction
between two gram and three gram if two
gram increased the surviving words from
let's say 70 to 75 3 gram also had 75
exact same ones
uh problem with number of you reviews i
mentioned that we couldn't go any
further than three
therefore it is something we would
push for content constraint
uh is also related to the previous
bullet point because if you increase the
number of reviews
then possibly uh more
subsets will survive in content
constraint which
uh in which we were trying to look at a
percentage
of corpus to appear in the subset say
one percent i really tried low
numbers uh for these like point five
percent one percent but
for two reviews none of them for two
products
none of the subsets survived
so that was another issue
choosing the right threshold um we chose
some arbitrary numbers and i'm totally
aware of it
and in most cases those decisions were
based on limiting into a dimension
that uh that was reasonable so when we
were
playing with the numbers looking at the
numbers uh you look at the distribution
of it and
there were some clear points where
cutting like they were more
accumulated in one region so if you cut
it off
at those sweet spots that we thought
were sweet spots but
there's not enough data to support our
claim
or the numbers we picked so that's
uh something to be further investigated
uh let's see questions
overall
all right um like i said i have a bunch
of other slides but
due to the time uh
limit i will not share it right now i
can share my presentation or my thesis
which has
all the possible things i had to really
squeeze in
um the important parts for this
presentation but
i can share that but thank you for
listening
awesome thank you so much leo and and
ryan for
for sharing that thank you
thank you for having me yeah definitely
um i guess so we can move on to
lightning talks at this time
um i didn't see anybody post lightning
talk ideas but just as a reminder
lightning talks are
um can be about any data science topic
in any any format
um between five and ten minutes or less
than that
um so does anyone want to present a
topic at this time
i've got one i'm still here
cool yeah we could you want to go first
mark
uh sure see if i can do
if i can do this oh
sure okay uh in case you haven't seen it
microsoft just announced an emergency
patch
uh everyone who's working on windows
even as far
back as windows 7 should apply this
patch
it's uh it's a vulnerability in the uh
print server
for microsoft windows so
security alert uh the next
uh is uh there's some kd nugget
articles that are worth reading um here
here is a
weight watcher uh library that'll tell
you that could tell you whether or not
your
machine learning model is over trained
i will i will i will store
or excuse me i will post the links to
these
everything that i'm going to show you in
the meetup page
for this meeting
okay moving on an automated data
wrangling article
from uh catalyst cooperative uh
it's it's a longish yard it's a longish
article uh
but when it comes to data wrangling i'm
a big proponent of trying to move as
close as we can to
um to automation
uh whenever whenever possible and uh so
there's there's plenty of uh stuff that
you can come in there
uh come away from this article
uh with some ideas and thing you things
to try
so anyway hollow hollow clean being the
first one that they
that they show you a
github repository called soda
and if you've already got your data
into rows into rows and columns into a
table format
soda can be used to
[Music]
check the goodness of the data or check
for missing data
you you create a a yaml file
and kind of specify what what kind of
constraints you wanted to check against
and then it genera
dynamically generates the sql to go out
and look at the table that you've you've
captured on a variety of different
um let's see right
so uh
these these different uh microsoft sql
server postgres
snowflake apache hive um google bigquery
etc so it will generate the sql
and and let you know whether or not
you're you're
missing values and uh it's kind of like
data profiler for
pandas except that it is for any any
kind of row and column data
that you've already gotten
leo mentioned a semantic search and this
brings us back to another kd nuggets
article
uh measuring meeting from
jacquard to burt and
once again this is in the realm of
natural language processing
i i will post the i will post the
article
and i think yeah this is the
this is the article from which i got the
the artie's
opening opening statements which is uh
if you've got a 1.6 trillion dollar
company
based on uh samantha based on similarity
it's probably worth uh worth your time
to at least look at it
and then finally and
medium.com has an article on several
seven different types of classification
using python
uh uh definitely a half an hour read
even if you don't um get out your get
out your
uh python or or jupiter notebook
and do any of these and plenty of code
uh plenty of code examples
to show to show you what's going on and
they're using a large data set
i think it's from belgium um
belgium banking uh datadump
so there's plenty of data plenty of data
that you can get to
through the article and then all the
code examples
um to take you through
classification different classifications
and i don't know where i am in terms of
five minutes but
that's what i wanted to show you
thank you cool thanks mark
um anyone else want to give a lightning
talk
anyone
okay well if not um i guess we can end a
little early
just a quick reminder that these
sessions are recorded and will be posted
to the
pi data youtube channel so you can
search um
pi data triangle and you can look
through any old recordings that we have
and then lastly our next meetup will be
wednesday september 24th september 1st
at 6 pm
thanks leo thanks for uh ryan and mark
for contributing appreciate it thanks so
much for your presentations
[Music]
hopefully we can meet one day and have
some beer together
oh man
[Laughter]
have a good night guys you too bye
goodnight everyone